sie hatten keine chance quaas am
sulaimani und ein weiterer ranghoher
general der präzise luftschlag in bagdad
von us-präsident chance selbst
angeordnet
das ziel den iran von künftigen
angriffen abzuhalten
doch die iranische führung antwortet
schnell und vor allem deutlich so
kündigt der religiöse und politische
führer des landes ayatollah khomeini
vergeltung an
der widerstand gegen die feinde werde
nun mit doppelten ansporn geführt
ähnlich der iranische aussenminister
java tarif die bosheit und dummheit der
terroristischen amerikanischen einheiten
bei der ermordung von general store im
werden zweifellos den widerstand in der
region und der welt sterben die
bedeutung von sulimani in der region ist
enorm einst vorzeige soldat wurde er
später kommandeur der iranischen al quds
einer eliteeinheit der revolutionsgarde
er galt als top stratege und soll die
fäden im nahen und mittleren osten
gezogen haben gleichzeitig soll er
hinter den gewalttätigen angriffen auf
die us-botschaft im irak stehen aus
sicht der usa ein weiteres puzzlestück
ähnlich wie ein drohen abschuss durch
den iran vor wenigen monaten doch
gegenwind kommt auch aus washington
trump hatte den angriff am kongress
vorbei befohlen nach dem ehemaligen vize
präsident und jetzigen
präsidentschaftskandidaten joe biden ist
das eine eskalation der lage
so stehe die usa am rande eines größeren
konflikt ob die neueste entwicklung
potenzial zur eskalation hat der
irakische außenminister warnt jetzt
zumindest vor einem krieg in der region
doch die menschen wollen nicht zwischen
die fronten geraten
wir haben den iranischen einfluss im
irak von anfang an nicht gewollt und
auch die amerikaner sollen sich nicht in
unsere angelegenheiten einmischen
wir wollen nicht in einen konflikt
zwischen den amerikanern und iranern
geraten
die us-regierung rief derweil ihre
bürger auf den irak umgehend zu
verlassen